today on the matt welsh show we have
heard a lot about the need for evidence
but
many of the people in the media
screaming about the alleged lack of
evidence of voter fraud have themselves
advanced many wild claims and recently
and insisted that we shouldn't require
evidence to believe those so we'll go
over some of those wild claims today
also five headlines including
some in the american public beginning to
stand up and resist
the unconstitutional lockdown orders
this is what's needed if we're ever
gonna be free again in this country and
our daily cancellation will cancel a
woman in canada who successfully shut
down a pop-up restaurant
because it had committed the sin of
cultural appropriation
but we're also going to cancel the owner
of that restaurant for caving to the
outrage mob that's where we're at right
now it's just going to be a
cavalcade of cancellations all that
coming up but first i want to tell you
uh about our good friends over vincero
watches
you know there's nothing better than
having a good quality watch i think
and it's it's just it's just something
especially if you're really no matter
what you're doing
if you're dressing up in a formal
occasion or
you know if you're just going out
running errands whatever you're doing it
really ties everything together and it
makes you feel a lot better when you
have a good quality watch
vincero you can't get better than that
they're dedicated to the craft they put
the time and effort into crafting
timepieces
so you can wear them day after day head
over to venturawatches.com walsh
don't hesitate right now they're having
a site-wide sale up to 15
off anything on their site plus they
make the perfect gift you know we're
getting into the holiday season
um and you're looking what kind of what
kind of gift can you get someone well
you can never go wrong with a watch
especially a ventura watch
a ventura offers free shipping 30 day
returns and guarantees for watches for
two years
and the great thing is you know what i
always say about ventura watches
is they're affordable but not cheap and
there's there's a big difference
between those two things especially with
watches you know you're wearing a cheap
watch you can tell
things practically falling apart these
are not cheap but they're affordable you
can afford them but they're extremely
well made high quality and they look
great
you can continue to support this brand
as they continue to support the matt
wall show and ask you to do that go to
venturawatches.com forward slash wall
stretch
v-i-n-c-e-r-o watches dot com
forward slash walsh take advantage of
this sale opportunity and get uh one of
my go-to watches at such a great price
you can go to the website and check
those out
like i said these are timepieces you
will enjoy wearing every single day
if you don't ventura will make it right
that's their promise if you don't love
it they'll make it right by you
but i think they will that's vincero
vincerowatches.com
you know there is no doubt that some of
the voter fraud allegations
we have heard over the past few weeks
are nothing short of
extraordinary the claim that donald
trump won in a landslide but the victory
was taken from him by
voting machines that have been rigged to
switch millions of votes from himself to
biden
and that many powerful people to include
the republican georgia the republican
governor of georgia as has now been
alleged by sydney powell
were in on or aware of this scam
is one that should not be accepted at
face value evidence is needed
the trump campaign released a statement
on sunday night announcing that
sydney powell is not a part of the
president's legal team and is practicing
law on her own quote unquote
this is helpful because some of the
other issues raised by trump's official
team problems with mail and
voting early voting poll watchers being
banned from polling stations etc
would seem to be far less cinematic in
scope and far more provable
but in those cases too the claims must
be evaluated based on evidence of course
as for the voting machine conspiracy it
will ultimately prove to be
either the greatest crime in american
history or one of the greatest one of
the most outlandish hoaxes in american
history
time and evidence will tell which is
which but after time passes
and the evidence or lack thereof is
presented will it matter
will anyone adjust their initial views
accordingly
the challenge now is that no matter the
issue fewer and fewer people
are persuadable fewer fewer people will
alter their views to conform with the
evidence
this is not simply the result of
stubborn ignorance on the part of the
american public
that's how the media wants to spin it
putting all the blame on you
for not knowing who to trust in truth
though most people have made the very
correct observation
that mainstream sources of information
are nakedly partisan
and therefore untrustworthy nobody is
persuaded by arguments advanced by
sources
they don't trust even if the arguments
are good
they're going to fall on deaf ears if
they're made by known con artists and
hatchet men
you know you might not even believe a
man who walks into the house soaking wet
and tells you it's raining if he's
already lied to you a dozen times that
day
so this level of extreme skepticism
directed towards
someone who has so thoroughly demolished
their own credibility is
entirely warranted the problem is that
hyper skepticism towards
one source of information can sometimes
lead to blind faith in another
competing source of information bad
actors enter into the vacuum
make sinister use of the crisis of trust
by presenting themselves as the real
truth-tellers and a public exhausted by
lies
desperate for the truth may be led into
the very pit they've been studiously
avoiding by someone who echoes their
skepticism
and exploits it for his or her own ends
but a few of the
self-professed real truth-tellers may
actually be real truth-tellers promising
to
tell you what's really going on and then
actually telling you what's really going
on
and listening to them will lead you not
into the pit where
they can keep you confused and monetize
your confusion
which is what most of the media is
interested in doing but out into the
clean air and sunlight where you can
see clearly and understand these are not
messiahs but simply honest people who
care about what's true
and wish to share whatever truths they
know with you
the task is always to discern which is
which and who is who but that's
hard to do in the dark amid the noise
and the chaos
i think the only way to do it is to
maintain a healthy skepticism but an
open mind willing to believe
anything that's logically possible so
long as good reason is presented to
believe it
one way to tell the real truth teller
from the con men
is that the former the real truth teller
wants us to have this discerning and
thoughtfully skeptical attitude
even towards themselves the latter
demands trust they haven't earned
and expects you to believe without
providing good reason to believe
now we know that the mainstream media
falls into this latter con man category
precisely for this reason
they bloviate about the need for
evidence of voter fraud and i agree with
them
but they do not agree with them until
this moment they have treated
evidence as irrelevant in principle
irrelevant
not just irrelevant but we've been
repeatedly told that to ask for evidence
or reserve judgment until evidence is
presented is a sign of sexism or racism
or
insufficient faith in the doctrines of
the day
from the left in the media we have been
given the anti-evidence slogan of
believe women
we've been thus instructed to blindly
believe the rape and assault claims made
by many women though
as tara reid can attest not all women
based solely on their word alone it's
not just that the people screaming
we need evidence today we're okay with
little or no evidence during the me too
craze or the kavanaugh hearings
but that believing without evidence back
then was put forward as a sign of virtue
the same with the recent hysteria over
police shootings the media on the left
certainly did not wait for evidence
before accusing police officers of
committing racist hate crimes in the
line of duty
they took the blm narrative as gospel
truth
and demanded that the american public do
the same and if you said hey
wait a second let's wait for the
evidence you were slandered as racist
now we could go on for quite a while
listing all the claims
that the media has recently advanced
without evidence longer if we list every
debunked
hate crime hoax separately which would
take us all day
for now we'll just file them all under
the label jesse smallett etc
last week joe biden as you can see here
provided another example
of the left's distaste for evidence when
he sent out a tweet
implying that trans people are the
victims of a hate crime epidemic
this was during the trans day of
remembrance which happened last week i
don't know if you're aware of that
now there's no evidence of this epidemic
yet
it is referred to as a self-evident fact
by the people who now pretend
to pretend to think that conclusions
should be grounded in provable reality
and what they do with that by the way is
they just they they list every single
trans person who is murdered
and then they imply or outright state
that every single one of those murders
are hate crimes
with zero evidence
of course no list list of evidenceless
claims
validated and amplified by the media
would be complete without mentioning the
parade of accusations made against
donald trump
over the last four years five years
starting with the accusation he's a
russian spy
there have been as well many claims
related to the lockdowns and mask usage
namely that they work which we are
expected to believe potentially to the
point of giving up our livelihoods
even though the evidence is at a minimum
insufficient
we could also add the claims that men
can get pregnant and women can have
penises
these claims certainly lack evidence to
put it mildly and yet
that's not supposed to prevent us from
accepting and repeating them
the point is that the media and the left
have a quite selective passion
for facts and evidence and this is why
they have no credibility when they cry
about a lack of evidence for voter fraud
it's also why nobody cares or is
persuaded
when they make the case that we need to
see evidence and nobody's convinced by
their interpretation
of the evidence that is provided nobody
trusts them
and they want to blame everyone else for
that but it's their fault
this is what their dishonesty and their
propagandizing has done
it's the monster they have created 100
their own fault now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
okay before we move on to five headlines
i want to tell you about paint your life
listen um holiday is coming up
and you're trying to think of what's
what's a good gift a gift that
you know it's it's uh it's an affordable
gift but also one that that's
thoughtful and i'll tell you right now
paint your life
is the way to go um you couldn't this
this this is going to be the
the hit of of the christmas party or
whatever you're doing this will be the
hit right now if you go with paint your
life
if you want to give a truly meaningful
gift you've got to try
paintyourlife.com you get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo
at a really affordable price you could
send any picture
whether it's yourself your children um
family a special place a cherished pet
combined or you could combine photos
into one paint so you could
take a photo that exists um in a moment
that you want to capture
or a moment that you haven't had a
chance to capture and you can create it
with paint your life
with paint your life's compilation
portraits you can bring together family
members who never had the chance to meet
create a portrait of the whole family
without the need for everyone to be
there
for a family photo choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect it's quick
it's easy
you get a hand-painted portrait in about
three weeks it is that quick um
and i have uh our paint your life i'm
always telling you about our paint your
life
picture that we have hanging up in our
living room we're really proud of it it
looks great
great conversation piece and um i was i
was especially
impressed with how quick the whole
process was and how easy it was at least
on my end
you know the all the hard stuff is on
their part all i had to do was tell them
what i wanted send them a picture
and they took care of it at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting
your money is refunded guaranteed but i
think you will love it but if
you don't you get the money back and
right now is a limited time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and
free shipping so to get this special
offer you don't want to miss out on text
the word matt
to 64 000 that's matt to 64 000 text
matt
matt 264 000 paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most
okay uh number one reading from buffalo
news it says a gathering of about 50
business owners and their supporters
inside an orchard park
gym uh shut down by covet 19
restrictions turned into a confrontation
with erie county authorities on friday
night
the owner of the gym athletes unleashed
on california road
pretty sure it's athletes unleashed on
california road that's not all one name
of the gym
describes the gathering as a protest of
the state's orange zone regulations that
have closed gym salons and other
businesses deemed non-essential
no one was no one was cited no arrests
were made
according to two people who attended but
video the incident shows an erie county
health inspector
accompanied by three sheriff's deputies
arriving about 20 minutes after the
gathering began
there's the the set up for it so there's
the gathering there at the gym
health inspectors show up and rather
than reading a description let's just
play the video
which i think is one of the most
beautiful videos you'll ever see i i
found this to be
truly inspiring uh and i say that not
sarcastically whatsoever
watch this people actually work for
their money
and they don't want to lose their
livelihood i've lost friends
who've killed themselves i've seen
clients die because they've lost their
livelihood
i'm sorry to hear that i know you are
and i'm just i'm asking for you to guys
have some compassion
for the people that have lost everything
we do have compassion for
people okay well compassion
well her job is well no no your job is
to remove people that are not wanted
here you have a problem
they're not you're just hiding in your
name
they're just doing their job there we go
you should all be wearing moms
don't worry about my health my health
isn't your concern you're meant to be
wearing a mosque
okay well then write me up it's the law
okay then then take me to jail
then take me to jail show me the law
anyway
you have to leave you guys have to leave
yeah you have to leave
now you're trespassing without a
warranty
you don't get to violate the
consequences
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
there you go and that see this is
exactly what needs to happen and there
have been
several videos um this is the best one i
think but over the last few days there's
been several videos like this
uh there's also a video of uh which
which we're not gonna play but you could
find online
of the governor of new jersey being
confronted by
some of it by some you know new jersey
citizens because he's sitting at a
restaurant without a mask you know this
sort of thing we're seeing more of this
this is what needs to happen um we need
to get to a point where we're just going
to say you know what i'm not
i i'm not going to listen to it i'm not
going to do it
you know uh call call their bluff
especially when it comes to these
ridiculous rules for thanksgiving
call their bluff that's this is the only
appropriate response as americans if we
ever want to be free again
there's there's a real precedent being
set here which is which is
which has always been my concern has
been the concern of everyone is a
critic of the lockdowns it's what's
happening right now is a problem
also the precedent for the future what's
the limiting principle when does this go
away
and because the government has announced
that it has the right to do this
to shut down your business to tell you
how many people you can have in your own
home
to tell you that you have to wear masks
in your own home
that's the latest madness from
pennsylvania now
actually passing uh i don't want to call
it a law it's not a law this is just a
declaration a decree uh from on high
from the
from the from the emperor of
pennsylvania that
in your own home you have to wear a mask
if you have a visitor over
and if they have the right to do this
the power to do it the authority to do
it
um when does it end when does it go away
and
they can do it again anytime they want
no but when when you get to there's a
there's a
vaccine for the coronavirus okay that
gets under control
and then what about next flu season we
have a bad flu season
tens of thousands of people are dying i
mean these are these are people who are
dying
the flu is a serious illness it is
well if we're gonna say you gotta wear
masks we're gonna we're gonna you know
to save lives we're gonna shut down
businesses we're gonna have capacity
limits
10 p.m curfew that saves lives well why
not save lives again
the only way to put a stop to it the
only way is for people to just
stand up and say no i'm not going to
listen you want to barge into people's
homes and arrest
everyone on thanksgiving you want you
want to do that then go ahead and do it
all these business owners just open your
business that's what i would say just
open it
and go about open your business open it
up
call their bluff all right let's um
let's go to this here's a local news
station orlando six with
uh with an interesting report watch this
today the holocaust memorial resource
and education center
is showcasing a new exhibit it displays
powerful images taken after the death of
george floyd
as news 6's azzy castro got a look at
this exhibit and spoke to the
photographer who captured moments
he says he'll never forget when you walk
inside the holocaust
center in maitland you'll be able to see
some of the faces of those who mourn the
death of george floyd
a black man who died in police custody
in minneapolis on memorial day
his death sparked protests across the
city
and around the country the portraits
captured by photographer john noltler
when george floyd was killed that
happened
11.6 miles north of my house
and i knew with a piece of my mind's
goal
being to hear voices that aren't always
heard
as well as they should be i knew that i
wanted to go up to that site
just days after floyd's death noltner
came to the site where dozens were
gathering
many who were still trying to process
the tragedy
in their community and he decided to
capture the tears
behind his lens what was the vibe what
was the feeling that you were
feeling when you arrived to that
location
there was clearly pain and frustration
and mourning happening but it was a
space that was open to anybody who
wanted to show up
and understand what was going on the
exhibit shows 45
strangers each of them sharing their own
message to the world
yeah not much needs to be said there i
don't think hopefully i don't have to
explain
why it's gratuitous and insane
to have a george floyd exhibit at the
holocaust museum
but the elevation the canonization
of guys like george floyd is one of the
most gratuitous and insane things
we've seen the left do in the last uh in
the last several years and that's that's
saying quite a lot
speaking of insane let's go to number
three here let's check in with joe biden
um here's what here's what joe biden is
maybe you can interpret this for me i'm
having a little bit of trouble but
here's uh
here's the latest from from joe biden
here's what he's thinking and talking
about listen
they talked about that in some detail
thirdly
we discussed the need to help states
with title 32 funding
for the national guard that's a fancy
way of saying governors
governors need to be able to get funding
when they dispel when they just they
need to uh
and bring bring their national guard
into play
and national guards are going to have to
play this it cost a lot of money just
think that's
that's how bad it is right now and i
know we we see this
we've seen this kind of thing many times
from joe biden of course
uh but still that's how bad it is right
now
if he does become president and he he
you know his
his win is legally certified becomes
president
that's how bad it is now before he has
actually taken on the most stressful job
on earth and and aged you know a few
more years
how are we going to know that we are we
are entering into a
potentially unprecedented uh territory
how are we going to know
when joe biden gets to the point where
he has completely lost his mind which i
feel very confident if he is the
president that will happen
during his first term i feel completely
confident now he's already losing it
without taking on i mean think about it
you know
if if you had a 78 year old many of us
have been in this situation
you've got a grandfather or a parent
who's you know um who's going down this
path
and think about your own life how
quickly this disease progresses
and usually that's with like a
grandparent who's retired
and uh and but but and not only does it
have it certainly doesn't have the most
stressful job on planet earth
so you think about how quickly that
progresses
and now imagine in your own life your
grandparent had the most stressful job
on earth
it's gonna be bad but how do we know
when he gets to the point where he
completely loses his mind are they gonna
tell us
or is camilla harris just gonna sort of
assume the role of president
uh behind the scenes and and uh and you
know
we're we're just not gonna be told
number four a man named orlando hall
was executed by the federal government a
couple of days ago um
many on the left were upset that this
man was executed
um here's keith boykin of cnn he sent
out this tweet
orlando hall was executed last night
hall was a black man convicted by an
all-white jury he's the eighth person
executed this year by the trump
administration
there were no federal executions under
president obama and biden plans to end
them as well
and then he talks later on in the threat
about how he's against that capital
punishment and so on
mentioning the race of the guy obviously
implying that there's something racist
going on here now
if you're wondering what orlando hall
did to uh deserve
and to earn himself capital punishment
in fact i was going to read a
description of the crime to you
report here in nbc news um
but it's it's so graphic that i
i it's and too disturbing to even read
what i'll say is that he
he he along with some accomplices uh
abducted a child a 16 year old child
um tortured and raped her over the
course of
several days i believe uh doused her
with gasoline
beat her with a shovel and then buried
her alive
so that's what he did that's how he got
himself the death penalty
by the way his victim also
black you love how
the victims are always erased in these
situations
always a race the left always erases the
victims
you know this is the kind of thing i i
i've talked about uh capital punishment
a lot on this show
over the years and i've kind of talked
about how i've i've
wrestled with it and i've been back i
used to be against capital punishment
over time i've sort of
been back and forth on it i'm at the
point right now
where i don't i'm not even sure maybe
maybe part of this is i'm sure part of
this is emotional but
i'm not even sure what i was wrestling
with i'm at a point now where it seems
so clear to me
obviously someone like this you execute
them what else would you do with them
the only problem i have is that it took
so long this crime happened uh
i'm not sure when this happened this
happened
let's see i'm not sure so years ago it
happened happened several years ago as
always 1994 that's when it happened
i didn't realize it was that long ago so
this happened this happened like 25
years ago
that's my only problem executions should
be
you get the conviction they're found
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt
um and take them out back
that day and dispatch them
it is it is a it is a injustice
to society that society is expected to
house these people
and feed them um and protect them
you know a lot of times in in you know
protective custody in prison
because the people that get capital
punishment a lot of them especially
they're committing sexual crimes against
children
they're so evil and disgusting that even
their other fellow convicted criminals
don't want to be around them
and so we have to pay extra to protect
them
from their other fellow criminals that's
the injustice
is the burden on society to keep this
person alive
so he should have been executed 25 years
ago
[Music]
but i'm relieved and happy that it
happened now
society is a little bit better off today
without this monstrous
despicable evil scumbag five
finally speaking of which um i'm going
to play something for you
i'll have much more to say about it
later probably tomorrow because what
you're about to witness
is just begging for a daily cancellation
um so we'll we'll do that probably
tomorrow but for now
i just want to play this for you because
i just saw it and i have to play it this
is being shared on social media kind of
going viral
um it's from a doc an hbo documentary i
think the
i believe the documentary is called
trans hood um
on hbo anyway check it out here it is
good morning today we choose to
recognize
honor love and celebrate anyone here
who would claim their identity publicly
as lesbian
gay bisexual transgender queer
or questioning intersex pansexual
asexual or any category that i've left
out
this is phoenix
[Music]
okay you can tell them that
[Music]
okay phoenix would like you to know that
she's a girl and she prefers
she and her pronouns
may you be well safe and whole
we honor you exactly as you are
okay i'm only going to say uh just two
two quick things about
what you just saw more to come later but
first of all as i always point out
in a healthy and well-adjusted society
that video would end with police
breaking down the door and arresting
every single adult in the building
and hauling them away in cuffs and then
even better in a really healthy society
as they're being frog marched um out to
the uh out to the big
bus or van where they're all going to be
taken to prison
the people in the town would be gathered
around like throwing tomatoes at them
and shouting at them
that that's how you know would be in a
really healthy society
because that ritualized child abuse that
you just saw that is the appropriate
response to it
so that's my first observation my second
observation is you saw in the video
there
quickly it kind of scanned to the um i'm
not even going to call it a congregation
well maybe it is a congregation
you know it's a this is basically a
satanic temple that you just saw
and so you saw the congregation at the
satanic temple
satanic temple by another name
but what did you notice what what was
missing
in the audience who was missing
men fathers it was almost entirely women
it was women up on stage of course there
was a woman dragging this poor child up
there
it was the mother i i hesitate to even
call her mother but it was the mother
dragging her up no father in sight i
don't know if the father was there or
not he wasn't he wasn't on stage
mostly women not a lot of men
um not a lot of fathers
that's not a coincidence is all i'll say
but as i said more
more more on that tomorrow okay before
we get to our daily cancellation
i want to tell you about um lifelock you
know our great sponsors we're always
telling you about and
now's especially time good time to hear
about it because with the holiday season
people are spending
you're online you're you're buying
things online
um and cyber criminals are also
online taking advantage of things cyber
criminals often hide
malware in emails these deceptive emails
can look like real invoices
invites or payment information with a
document attached to it the attached the
attachments contain text and images
that look legitimate but when you click
on them a pop-up ad appears
promote you know asking you to enable
content or enable editing
if you do this the attachment will
install malware on your computer
the thing is these hackers are getting
um
they're they're very clever and they
know how to make things look legitimate
so even if you feel like
you know you're not going to fall for
these kinds of scams well they're always
they're always adapting and they're
trying to get people just like you and
that's why you need lifelock it's
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives
this holiday season you could miss
certain identity threats if you're just
monitoring your credit or your bank
statements
that's why you need lifelock the leader
in identity theft protection lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats
like for example if your social security
number is for sale and dark web
stuff like that that you wouldn't be
able to find out on your own if they
detect your information being used in
their network
they're going to send you an alert and
if anything ever does happen and you
have a problem
they're also going to be there to help
you restore and get your identity back
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but lifelock
can help you feel warm and protected
this holiday season save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifeblock.com
walsh for 25 off one other note
um before we move on here thanksgiving
of course
is almost here and that means that black
friday is also almost here
since last uh last year's black friday
deal we've been consistently adding more
features and products to our membership
program
we're really so excited about it to name
a few things we've added more
exclusive readers past content our
insider and above members can now stream
our content on apple tv and roku
i know i hear from a lot of people that
are using apple tv or roku now to
to watch the shows and we're currently
adding the entire prageru
catalog behind our paywall that's going
to be up there pretty soon
so if your account your account now
comes with custom badges that you can
earn by
participating in current events if
you're an all-access member you get to
join the all-access live discussions our
exclusive daily live streams
with me or one of the other hosts that
was something we didn't have i don't
think we had that last year so that's
another added benefit
we're also continuing to add new
features and products um like well i
already mentioned the entire prageru
catalog and many other things um and
also more content
candace owens could be joining uh
joining the team very soon
launching a new show with us early next
year so needless to say we're pretty
excited about everything we've got
coming up
and that's why you want to take
advantage of the black friday deal you
don't want to miss it
now today for our daily cancellation
we're going to be canceling this person
her name is
evie quang she works for the toronto
star
she was recently horribly offended by
some of the offerings at a pop-up broth
bar
inside of an athletic apparel store in
toronto of course many questions are
immediately raised about
why there's such a thing as a broth bar
and what that is exactly and
why it's inside of an athletic apparel
store and how
any human could possibly manage to be
offended by broth
we may be able to answer some of those
questions in due course
as we proceed but first uh to evie
quang's tweets
she says there's a whole this is a long
tweet thread
as she goes on about it she says a white
owned trendy spot on osington
is selling bone broth across from golden
turtle pho
also sexualizing jerk sauce and pho hot
sauce
and making super food dumplings for
profit
y'all i'm sick the cultures they are
taking from literally fight
daily for legitimacy the wellness
cleansing of the food
the lack of historical understanding and
the number of followers is alarming
i'm not trying to knock small businesses
and it is china by the way t-r-y-n-a
i'm not trying to knock small businesses
but damn this one hurt
i legit throughout my chinese food
lunches because white kids would make
fun of it all day
i bought into pizza day and dry ass
turkey burgers
so did so did many others and now you're
taking our culture and selling it
and people think it's legit damn it took
hella unlearning and relearning to love
my identity to get over that
don't come at me with organic grass-fed
immunity dumplings
it's zhao long bao i have no idea if i
pronounced that correctly surely if i
did not i am racist
um anyway she continues and while you're
here
support your local chinatown little
india little jamaica little tibet
koreatown j-town and spots our aunties
and uncles opened
uh moving here to support their families
know that they've had to assimilate too
okay a lot of pro that was hard first of
all this is someone who works in the
media
this is i guess a journalist or
something and that's how she writes
words like china hella that's a problem
but to translate quang is upset that
this business is
is selling a few traditionally asian
food products
somehow the existence of bone broth
cooked by someone who is not asian
has caused her to flash back to some
teasing she received in grade school
and because she has this weird emotional
association between broth and bullying
she believes that the business that
produced the broth
should be destroyed it is after all
cultural appropriation
she says now something tells me and i
could be wrong
but i don't think i am something tells
me that miss kwong
has never once complained about
restaurants run by asians
selling hamburgers or pizza and that's a
problem because
if we're going to play this game then it
must be played consistently and equally
it never is you never hear anyone
complain about non-white people
selling products that quote belong to
white people
which objectively speaking in a vacuum
is fine because nothing
belongs to white people as a group but
also
nothing belongs to any other group or
race or ethnicity or culture
as a group asians don't own broth
they don't own asian any asian food i
got news for you
individual items of food can be owned
but entire types of food cannot be owned
ihop owns the pancakes it makes
but who owns pancakes in general what
group lays claim to the concept of
pancakes
answer none no group pancakes are the
property of the whole human race
and what a glorious thing that is and
guess what
what we call asian food is also the
property of the whole human race
anyone can make it anyone can eat it
anyone can sell it
so evie kwong you don't own asian food i
own it just as much as you do
guess what i am just as much as you
allowed to make it sell it eat it
i have just as much of a claim to it as
you do
that's the way it goes in fact the
cultural appropriation charge is never
as absurd as it is
in relation to cuisine because cuisine
especially cannot be owned by any group
of people
as there's probably no dish you could
possibly name which originates entirely
with one group and has remained
unchanged and uninfluenced for centuries
there may be some dishes like that but
they're few and far between
almost all foods and dishes are a fusion
of different influences and have changed
and been adapted and adopted over time
i'm no historian of pho but as far as
i'm aware
pha itself has very heavy french
influences
this is a fact overlooked by miss quang
these kinds of facts
are always overlooked by the people who
rail against cultural appropriation
now i have to add one other thing it's
not just
evie getting canceled tonight i must
also cancel the business
that she herself canceled i'm afraid i
have to jump in with the pitchfork mob
but only because the business caved to
the pitchfork mob
you know after the outrage sparked by um
quang's psychotic tweets
the business called ripe nutrition
posted on instagram
the following message from its founder
this is what they said
over the course of the past 48 hours it
has come to my attention as the founder
of ripe nutrition
that i've made some mistakes big ones it
was important to me to take a moment to
collect my thoughts and decide how to
best address this situation
first i want to thank each and every
person who took the time to bring this
to my attention
something that i now realize should have
never been their burden to bear
is not the responsibility of people of
color to educate me a white woman
on why cultural appropriation isn't
acceptable the responsibility is mine
and mine alone
anyone who has spoken out about this
should never have had to do this work
and i apologize for my insensitivity
and ignorance as the founder of ripe
nutrition
oh dear god um we should note that
in spite of this groveling apology the
business was still kicked out of its
location in the apparel store so it was
still shut down
this is the way it always goes of course
the apologies never
make a difference they never have the
effect that the apologizer hopes for and
intends
never it doesn't matter they're not
going to go any easier on you just
because you apologize and that's why
everyone
must stop apologizing
i'm at the point where people who do
apologize
lose all sympathy from me if you're
going to cave and kowtow and prostrate
yourself
at the behest of these lunatics that i
am not going to defend you
why should i bother defending your
dignity and honor if you're just going
to set it on fire willingly anyway
i mean burden to bear the owner of this
company
actually just said that her broth was
somehow an emotional
burden that some in the public had to
bear as if there were people up
late at night tossing and turning
distraught because some white lady was
selling broth in an apparel store in
toronto
if any such person actually exists which
i doubt
if there's actually any person who is at
all traumatized
by this broth then they are mentally ill
and should be committed to an asylum
anyone who has ever felt any kind of
authentic distress
because the quote wrong race of person
was cooking a certain food
is not only a bigot but a lunatic
and that's exactly what you should say
to them when they try to cancel you
these lunatic bigots will never stop
will never slow down so long as there
are limp
spineless jellyfish-like creatures
floating around there
out there such as the owner of ripe
nutrition who can so easily be
manipulated and dominated
have some damn self-respect grow a spine
stand up for yourself you know
how about issuing a statement on your
little instagram account saying hey
guess what i'm not sorry it's broth
get over it you you insane babies
get over yourself how about that for a
statement
so everyone who complains about cultural
appropriation is canceled
and everyone who emboldens and
encourages and validates the complainers
is also cancelled cancelled cancelled
cancelled
that's how we're ending it today
but other than that hope you have a
great day and i'll talk to you tomorrow
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton